Вітання!
Ми зустрілися з вами на уроці
української мови в 6 класі.
З вами знову я – Юлія Набок-Бабенко!
Тема сьогоднішнього уроку:
«Узагальнення знань про числівник».
Разом із нами протягом уроку
будуть веселі друзі посіпаки,
які ставитимуть різноманітні питання,
шукатимуть на них відповіді,
помилятимуться
та виправлятимуть власні помилки.
Отож,
відновіть комікси з посіпаками.
А ви, друзі, знаєте, що таке числівник?
Звісно ж,
числівник – це самостійна частина мови,
що позначає число,
кількість або порядок при лічбі,
і відповідає на питання
котрий? скільки?
Якраз про це запитує наступний посіпака.
Скільки?
І котрий?
Кількісні та порядкові.
Пригадаймо,
що кількісні своєю чергою поділяються на:
власне кількісні (або ж цілі числа),
дробові, збірні та неозначено-кількісні.
Пригадали?
Отож, прості, складні та складені.
Пам’ятаєте, що прості
мають лише один корінь,
складні – два корені,
а складені – два і більше слова.
Будьмо редакторами!
Слід виправити
помилки у вживанні числівників.
Подивіться, друзі, уважно,
яка помилка закралася в цей допис?
Числівник сто
у всіх відмінках, окрім називного
(подекуди знахідного)
має закінчення -а.
Тож, ніякі стома не можуть бути,
а правильно сказати:
об’їмся ста бананами.
Як правильно? –
до ста не вистачає один банан.
Друзі, а скажіть, будь ласка,
краще і правильніше говорити:
не вистачає один банан
чи одного банана?
Не вистачає одного банана.
Вживаємо числівник в родовому відмінку.
Пограймо, друзі, у лото.
Візьміть аркуш паперу,
намалюйте на ньому п’ять колонок.
В першій колонці зазначте від 1 до 20,
в другій – від 21 до 40,
в третій – від 41 до 60,
в четвертій – від 61 до 80,
в п'ятій – від 81 до 100.
Далі запишіть будь-які числа,
які ви бажаєте,
але важливо, щоб вони входили до переліку,
зазначеного вгорі.
Наприклад, від 1 до 20:
я зазначила 3, 11, 17 -
це можуть бути різні числа на ваш вибір,
або, скажімо, 22, 30, 34 та інші.
Тобто, ми таким чином, створюємо
звичайну картку лото,
традиційну для цієї гри.
Виконали?
Нумо відповідати на запитання!
Якщо є серед перелічених цифр
потрібна вам, то ви обводите її.
Отож, перше питання.
Подивіться, чи є вона
на вашій картці лото.
Друге питання - яке число
між сімома і дев'ятьма?
Яке число? – вісім.
Тож, подивіться, чи є 8 у вашій картці,
а я теж зазирну.
Немає, мені не пощастило.
Третє - скільки років незалежній Україні?
Пам’ятаємо, що День Незалежності України
проголошено двадцять четвертого серпня
тисяча дев'ятсот дев'яносто першого року.
Спробуємо відняти: дві тисячі двадцять
мінус тисяча дев'ятсот дев'яносто один
і отримаємо - двадцять дев'ять.
Четверте запитання.
Мій День Народження – п'ятого числа.
Так, теж не пощастило мені цього разу.
Наступне.
Шосте запитання.
Пам’ятаємо, що День Незалежності святкують
Двадцять четвертого серпня.
Немає.
Сподіваюся, що вам пощастило більше.
Наступне - сьоме запитання.
Буде 94.
Є у вас таке число?
Якщо так, то вітаю.
Восьме запитання.
Подивіться, чи є серед переліку чисел
номер вашого будинку.
Номер мого будинку – 5.
Я пам’ятаю, що цього
числа немає в переліку.
Від 100 відніміть 40.
Буде 60.
Є у вас таке число?
Нумо рахувати разом.
Один, два, три, чотири,
п’ять, шість, сім, вісім,
дев’ять, десять, одинадцять, дванадцять,
тринадцять, чотирнадцять…
– п'ятнадцять літер.
Є таке число в мене?
На жаль, немає!
Порахуйте!
Якщо записати трьома великими літерами
«станція технічного обслуговування»,
то матимемо абревіатуру «СТО».
Наступне.
Пам’ятаймо,
що святкуємо День
захисника України 14 жовтня.
Отже,
чотирнадцять.
Знайшли? Молодці!
Пригадали?
Так, тридцять три!
Буде скільки? -
шістдесят чотири.
Останнє.
Це буде 99.
Є у вас?
Молодці!
Погляньте на свій аркуш лото.
Якщо ви обвели хоча б три цифри,
то вам пощастило сьогодні.
Якщо ви при цьому ще й правильно
назвали числівники,
то ви – найкращі учні школи онлайн!
Нумо практикувати разом!
Знайдіть код.
Погляньте на числівники,
але й не тільки числівники.
Запишіть кодом:
1 – числівник,
2 – не числівник.
Таким чином, ніби зашифруйте подані слова.
Якщо правильно закодували
наведені слова, то має бути так:
Перевіримо разом:
Один – числівник,
тому 1; одиниця – іменник
(відповідає на питання що?)
2; скільки – числівник;
вдруге (коли?) –
немає такого питання в числівника.
На питання коли? відповідає прислівник.
Дворічний (який?) – це прикметник.
Сотий (котрий?) – числівник.
Шістнадцять сотих (скільки?) – числівник.
Сто двадцять п’ять
(скільки?) – теж числівник.
П’ятірка – це іменник, адже
відповідає на питання що?
Двадцятип’ятирічний – це прикметник.
Мільйон (скільки?) – числівник
і мільйонер (хто?) – це слово є іменником.
Правильно зашифрували?
Молодці!
Посіпака наш просить ще про допомогу.
Отож, випишіть числівники,
визначте відмінок!
Випишіть числівники,
Перевіряємо разом!
9 липня –
дев’ятого –
цей числівник вжито у
формі родового відмінка.
Дві тисячі п’ятнадцятого –
теж родового відмінка.
Озвучує всіх восьмисот дев’яноста
дев’яти посіпак.
Будьмо уважними!
Озвучує кого? що? –
це питання якого відмінка?
Так, знахідного.
Наступне.
Відбувається одна тисяча дев’ятсот
шістдесят восьмого року.
року якого? –
це питання родового відмінка.
Вони існують мільйон років –
називний відмінок.
Є троє посіпак –
теж називний відмінок.
Наступне завдання.
Пам’ятаймо, що числівники 2, 3, 4
вимагають після себе
називного відмінка множини.
Більше 5 – родового відмінка множини.
Числівник один любить, коли поруч із ним
іменник в називному відмінку однини.
Якщо це складений числівник,
то звертаємо увагу на останнє слово
складеного числівника.
Відповідно, якщо один,
то поруч буде іменник в однині,
якщо 2, 3, 4 – іменник в множині
в називному відмінку,
якщо 5 і більше, то іменник
в родовому відмінку множини.
Три брати,
двадцять чотири доби,
п’ятнадцять кілометрів,
сто гривень,
півтори сторінки,
два лимони,
двісті п’ятдесят шість друзів,
двадцять перше лютого,
восьма година або ж вісім годин,
залежно від того, яким буде цей
числівник – порядковим або ж кількісним.
Знайди і виправ помилки
у прямій мові кожного з посіпак.
Як правильно сказати? -
із 12 квітня, так?
Адже іменник на позначення дат
вживається в родовому відмінку.
Кого? чого? – квітня.
Краще б сказати: «А що цього дня?»
або ж: «Що ми святкуємо цього дня?»
Як правильно вживати числівники
на позначення часу?
Пам’ятаємо, що
числівник, що позначає годину – це завжди
порядковий числівник
а хвилини вживаємо
як кількісний числівник.
Отож, я буду готовий…о шостій.
Пам’ятаємо, що говорячи про час,
слід вживати прийменник о,
а не у, і не в.
Йдемо о сьомій на концерт
або ж о дев’ятнадцятій, якщо це ввечері.
Концерт о дев’ятій!
Наступне завдання.
Запишіть у відповідному відмінку.
Перший посіпака просить
давальний відмінок.
Отож, один – одному,
чотири – чотирьом,
двадцять – двадцяти (двадцятьом),
сорок – сорока,
п’ятдесят сім – п’ятдесяти семи,
або ж (п’ятдесятьом сімом),
двісті сімдесят другий –
двісті сімдесят другому.
Ви помітили порядковий числівник,
який закрався вкінець.
У порядкових числівниках ми відмінюємо
лише останнє слово,
якщо цей числівник є складеним.
Інший посіпака просить
форму орудного відмінка.
Чотири – чотирма,
дев’ять – дев’ятьма (дев’ятьома),
тридцять – тридцятьма (тридцятьома),
сорок – сорока,
шістдесят шість – шістдесятьма шістьма
або ж (шістдесятьома шістьома),
вісімсот сімдесят третій –
вісімсот сімдесят третім.
Останній посіпака вимагає форму
місцевого відмінка:
два – на двох,
десять – на десяти (на десятьох),
вісімдесят – на вісімдесяти
(на вісімдесятьох),
сто – на ста,
мільйон дев’яносто три –
на мільйоні дев’яноста трьох,
п’ятсот одинадцятий –
на п’ятсот одинадцятому.
Незабаром пролунає дзвінок,
і варто вже підбивати підсумки
разом із нашими невгамовними посіпаками.
Я сподіваюся, що так!
Чекаю лише ваших вподобайків.
Сподіваюся, що таки сподобався!
Домашнє завдання.
Найкращі комікси ми покажемо
на наших онлайн-уроках.
Дякую вам, любі учні, за вашу увагу!
До нових зустрічей!